hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round seven of the LT
box my weight championship is dinkler
and vs sharma me dr of i will not
mention if it's a classical game or or
the armageddon but it's really a such a
wonderful game that it will be a
pleasure to guess where it's from the
classical or the armageddon now before
we get this show on the road i would
just like to mention some of you have
been asking me how come you're not
getting notifications from my channel
even though you are subscribed to the
channel now i always said i have no idea
but obviously it's an issue with youtube
and youtube members members of youtube
made a video on it it's a very short
video some I believe four or five
minutes I will put a link to it in the
description below I will be the first
thing you see in the description so if
you're interested about this issue do
check it out they explain it's very
nicely and well it would be just much
better than if I explained it in this
video so if it's happening to you and
you know if you're also experiencing
this do check it out now that being said
let's return to the game and it's also a
very special game for one more reason
but I will also mention that somewhat
later really just a wonderful mixture of
preparation and attacking creativity so
without further ado let's check it out
dingo opens with 2d for we have night to
have 6c for now with g6 and sorry about
that and we have f3 be empty room filled
we have d5 by mama dr of c captures
night captures and now II for pushing
the night back there is no knight on c3
so black and further now go for some
exchanges Knight back to b6 and now only
90 to c3 with Bishop to g7 by Mahmoud er
of not Bishop to e3 defending the d4
pawn and Mahmoud er of castles we have
Queen to d2 probably when preparing to
exchange bishops at some point and now
comes a five and here ding just grabs
more space in the center we have
d5 and now c6 attacking ding strong
center and h4 so this is nothing new
there are almost 100 games in the
database with this exact same setup h4
is the main idea in this position black
has a few kiddo in care of dark square
bishop you want to bust open the th file
here and then at some point
trade the dark dark square bishop sent
to checkmate the black King that's how
that's how it works so see capture Sun
d5 the Mainers reply eek after Sun d5
and out night 8 to d7 preparing to get
this night over to over to f6 with h5
biding Knight to f6 as planned with
captures here and now you although it is
principled to capture towards towards
the center here which would be a too
dangerous of a move because after Bishop
to h6 black will be in a lot of trouble
for example you could capture here
but then after captures captures you
allow Queen h6 check and then you have
to go for a nice walk with your king
which is not not something you want to
do so after this H capture some juices
with F captures on g6 and now ding just
castles Queen side with Bishop to d7
still the the main idea as it has been
played many times King Tubby one you
don't want your king and the C filed as
the black rook is well coming to occupy
that same file and now comes d6 a very
nice pawn already on the 6th rank it's a
nicely protected there and well you're
also open up this very important
diagonal for your light square bishop
you're somehow planning to get it all
the way there where it will be you know
very useful and here there are two games
in the database where Bishop f5 check
was played but white was able to win
both of them so people pretty much gave
up on that idea here the new idea is
efore and this is exactly what mama D ro
played so well it's not really that
strange they are both top elite players
so they know their theory we have F
captures on e4 and not Knight to g4
going after the dark square bishop here
of course ding doesn't want to part with
his very strong attacking bestow Bishop
g5 attacks the Queen Queen to e8 and now
Knight to f3 developing the knight also
blocking the F file because 92 f2 was a
threat you would lose one of your looks
so here the main idea again and we are
still in theory waters and it's already
moved 19 rook to f7 is the main idea
rook captures on c3 also is a
possibility there are two games one was
won by white white won by black the
notable one max Maxime racha racha in
versus Dolly's navara from 2012 European
Club Cup were after be captures Queen
captures a need for check was played but
after Bishop to d3 white was able to win
that game black it obviously didn't come
as too big of a surprise
so if David Navarro lost this would
black I I don't know what to make of it
but I'm sure I'm sure you can play it
but dingos for the main idea with rook
to have 7 and now Quinta II won with
ideas of some point maybe jumping to h4
where from where you can deliver a lot
of damage you know along BH file we've
roped a c5 and now what do you play here
here Queen to h4 is a bit too early
because black can either just grab here
and then the Rope will be guarding gage
so important you can just play h6 and
kick away the bishop and continue
playing the game if if white try
something sneaky like Bishop d3 you can
just capture it it's not a problem after
Knight captures you can go rook f2 and
white doesn't have a have any good
compensation for the piece a queen h7
doesn't really do anything the king will
be very safe there as the rook prevents
any checks along the F file so after
rook to c5 there are two games in the
database interestingly out of those two
games and in the database Bishop to e7
is the main move and the white was able
to win both of those games but here the
engine actually slightly prefers the
bishop to d2 to the Bishop to e7 that
was already played and this is what the
Dean goes for and it seems well it seems
that dink came fully prepared as this is
now a new move and it is the first time
where we have 21 move played that it is
only now that we have a completely new
game on our hands so a lot of theory
went into this game obviously both
building am a media of nudists and what
do you do here so the Kings are on
opposite sides of the board both castles
and as usual when you have a position
like this white will of course try to
attack on the King side black will try
to attack on the Queen side so here
Bishop to e6 Mammadov wants to somehow
get rid of this night here and then get
his Queen over to a4 to start an attack
against against the Dinks King so what
do you do here here I think
thinks preparation still leads into into
this position because here look the c1
the top right engine recommendation but
the ding plays d5 it is the engine
second recommendation and here I think
Bing is trying to catch mama dr off
guard as most likely like any top player
mama dear knows by heart they replied to
every engine stock recommendation but
maybe not to the engines second
recommendation so here Bing is basically
testing what mama Dora will do now and
well there are a couple of possibilities
you could go Knight to a4 what's say to
eliminate this night here and then go go
further forward with your plan
but mama D off says nope this pawn is
free for grabs and he decides to capture
it with Bishop captures on e5 so what do
you do here it's not all that great stew
capture the bishop you if you captured
and rook captures comes with an attack
on the Queen after you block 9f2 will
again win material here so ding plays
Bishop to d3 he was very much prepared
to give up the e5 pawn and here mama D
RF has to go for Knights to c4 just you
know put that night there on a very nice
square and after Bishop captures Bishop
captures not captures on c4 but rook
captures on c4 you will capture on e5
and after Knight captures black will
have this well a very nice position now
where the material on the board is equal
but you know black black will black will
definitely fight but here Knights the a4
was played by mama D off and this is a
mistake
so it's very interesting both of them
play the perfect game pretty much if you
ask the engine up until move 21 and this
is only move 23 and already my media
makes a mistake which I think it is
fascinating because I don't know it
maybe he doesn't know theory of this
line at all maybe he played it all you
know calculated all the moves but I
don't think that's the case but which is
always very interesting 20:21 moves
played you know with perfect theory and
then 2 moves after that you know you you
just make a mistake which ding takes
advantage of very nicely being plays
Knight captures on e5 with rook captures
on e5 attacking
Queen and only now Queen to h4 so what
what do you do here obviously you have
to block block the D H file and after
you can capture on c3 but here Mahmud ER
immediately plays rook to h5 pushes the
Queen back and we have Queen to g3 so
what do you do now
now the problem is there's always this
tension you have to keep in mind that if
white captures on h5 you will be forced
to capture with the Jeep on so here one
of your options is just the cap running
on h1 but then again you give white the
same you open H file and then you can go
nice the c5 just putting pressure on
white controlling b7 not allowing this
point to be pushed any further and it
would be the best course of action for
Mama dr but here mama dr of captured
instantly now this is if you don't gain
anything by capturing i was always told
you shouldn't capture because this seems
to only improve the position of white
bishop which is now just a monster as
black parted with his dark square bishop
so here white having the bishop pair the
semi-open h-file it's a very dangerous
game here Queen to a4 by moment Yara of
going after the a to pawn and here the
move that's really really really amazing
ding just ignores this threat and plays
d7 he says I don't care if you capture
an 82 I already have a pawn on these 7
and here's the here's the problem if you
capture with the Queen King c1 there's
no good continuation here Queen e1 check
you can go back up the b1 just block and
now you have a lot of problems your pawn
is ready to reach the d8 square the
queening square rookie fate doesn't stop
it because the row from d1 also controls
that square so you will have to capture
it but then you get the problem of this
tension that you were having on the
h-file rook captures G captures and
Queen B a check rook to f8 as the bishop
controls this diagonal and now after
Queen captures on b7 blacks position
just falls apart it's the queen is
really misplaced on a1 if you move it
there some captures on h7 is very strong
followed by Queen captures here and with
the bishop pair slicing all the way here
it's really impossible to play already
the thread is even just a
for the bishop there's there's no escape
here for black and it's not better to
capture with the bishop but Karis King
c1 you don't have anything here Queen
captures on d7 and being again
calculates everything perfectly captures
on h5g captures and now Bishop captures
on h7 just wins the queen that you will
get some material for it but it's not
enough captures captures Bishop Queen
will be of course superior to look
Knight and Bishop so after d7 mamedyarov
goes rogue back to d5 just blocks the
pawn here now while the bishop is here
the rook no longer controls the D file
but here dink has everything prepared
bishop c2 first attacking the Queen now
forcing the Queen to capture we have
Queen captures on d7 and out comes again
just a wonderful attacking move but I
feel free to pause the video and
continue this attack for white it's not
a crushing move immediately but it leads
to a very very powerful position for
white so I'll give you a couple of
seconds while I have a nice sip of my
water for those of you who were able to
do it from gratulations you have been
paying attention because we've discussed
from the moment that this video started
that this bishop has to who go to this
diagonal and this is exactly what doing
plays now look at how many juicy black
pieces are on this diagonal this is just
awesome for this light square bishop so
what do you do here obviously you will
capture once this is what mom and your
played with rook captures rook captures
now your bishop on e6 is under attack
and it's undefended if you move the
Queen but also your queen is under
attack so you have to you know deal with
both threats while still keeping an eye
on each other
and here again comes the move you have
to find it's not just enough to find
Bishop to b3 so again very you know
briefly pause the video and continue the
attack for white I'm just a nice idea
for those of you again who were able to
do it congratulations you are playing
the perfect attacking game and for those
who just want to enjoy the show Queen to
h4 yes that is a very nice move the
Queen controls the d8 square so here
you're already threatening rook to the
edge to win the Queen
so again mama D off as the thing was
playing this movement Dara was strolling
around the playing halt and as soon as
mama drf came back he immediately played
Knight to f6 and here you might think
but what's nice to have six does that
really stop something and you know III
already thought yeah you just capture
here and then you win the Queen that's
that's how chess works right well not
really mama dear I've had a really
excellent reply to this Bishop captures
and Bishop captures on b3 yes you do win
the Queen but you know it's not enough
to win the Queen if you're getting
checkmated rook if one check kink has
nowhere to go and here as of course the
bishop is walking the City Square it
would be very sad for them to finish the
game like this but here
dink continued the game again in the
best way so once again you're playing
this continue the perfect game sorry the
perfect attacking game for those of you
were able to do it just congratulations
this is you know move by move just just
a brilliancy rook to d6 just attack the
bishop twice what's black really gonna
do you can't defend it you have to keep
an eye on the night and f6 also so it's
a very natural move but you know when
you play against a guy like Mahmud yarv
you always have to double check or
triple check you know everything so mama
deriv capture done b3 but here didn't
just played rook captures on f6 and it
was in this position unmoved 34 that
shot him a media resigned the game and a
brilliant victory for fording leerin and
now i will mention it this was not a
normal getting game this was a game in
classical time format so two full points
for doing Lear and for this wonderful
achievement and once again okay let's
just say why the game ended here you
have to play something let's say you
capture here Queen captures there's the
threat of checkmate and also the threat
of losing the bishop so it doesn't
really matter what you reply you can
deliver check here
maybe to prevent checkmate captures the
clink after G capture send a capture
some b3 you're up a piece of course in a
completely winning endgame and if you
don't give you I don't
after Queen captures an f6 you could
play Queen f8
the block but again you can either just
trade pick up the bishop here
just everything everything wins so of
course my media knows this after rook
captures I have six he resigned and I
think it's really fascinating how up
until this point this was the moment
we're doing improved here we mentioned
that there are two games in the database
where Bishop e7 was played being
improved with Bishop to d2 and then
after Bishop to e6 he didn't play the
top angel recommendation but II five and
it was enough to confuse Mahmud II off
he did not know the exact reply to the
second thing engines recommendation by
heart and very quickly he blundered he
decided to go for the pawn and okay
Bishop d3 and now Knight if for a
mistake which ding took advantage of
perfectly and then we have this entire
beautiful game so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Ramachandran Venkatasubramanian
christophe journey one open door books
rocker my knee and daniel norwood for
contribution to my channel think a lot I
really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
most likely with another game from round
seven of the author box no a
championship but I'll probably do that
one tomorrow morning so you know enjoy
this one up until then I think I'll I
will see you soon have an excellent rest
of your day